but wait you've got sonic the hedgehog 2
out now i love the first one so what's
happening
in this one and who are you playing
i i play a character named randall and
uh you know which is because i i spend
my
my days playing chasing bad guys you
know i'm tough guy hondo you know
kicking down doors and chasing bad guys
and you know i got the the hondo scale
yeah and so in this movie in this movie
i smile a lot i show all the pearlies
i'll get to be goofy is that kind of fun
to play just such a dude it was i was
actually a fish out of water so i was
like i don't know if i'm doing a good
job because it's a cartoon now i played
a real person so i don't play a cartoon
i play a real person but you're talking
to tennis balls you know what i mean
because
well because sonic is not really
obviously
so they have a little stick in the
ground with a tennis ball and so you
have to talk to the tennis ball and then
later in post they put in the cartoon so
it was just so strange talking to a
tennis ball but uh but i got to i got to
talk to human beings james marsden uh
one of the stars yeah oh i love i've
seen the original time natasha rothwell
i get to play her kind of sweetheart
love interest yeah fiance thing so
there's a lot of romantic kissy vibe
yeah um
i'm not a big part of the movie but it's
a nice sweet little cameo where i get to
do my thing a lot of fun scenes with
james marsden there's a volleyball scene
that is hilarious um but it just was it
was just i got to go to hawaii i got to
play golf i got to talk to tennis balls
and there you go and i got to be goofy
fun and to be part of a franchise like
that it just i was going to say we will
see this movie one billion times in my
house like i've seen the the first one i
can't even tell you how many times well
my family my family like you know i'm
kind of cool because i was on young
arrests i was on criminal minds and now
i'm on i'm on swat yeah okay
but
28 years of the game i now have
officially arrived in my family because
i'm on sonic the hedgehog no it is it is
the weirdest thing i worked 20 years
right and then all of a sudden
the coolest thing my kids are like it's
like they're like yeah you're all right
and i worked with ariana grande on the
voice
and like all of a sudden they're like
you know her and i was like wait what
i'm somebody too
yes i do she's lovely but what
like that did it out of all the things
anyway
[Music]
you